[Music]
People with depression want the same
thing as anyone else.
We're all looking for love and this is true
no matter what we're dealing with on the inside.
Sometimes it's very hard to tell if someone
has a crush on you.
Whether they're happy and extroverted or quiet
and introverted. But there are a few simple
ways you might be able to tell even with people
who have depression.
They seem afraid of getting rejected.
Rejection is never fun, but in many ways,
it's just another part of love.
Most of us have felt the sting of rejection
in our lives before, and we've come to accept
it.
But this is true whether you have depression
or not.
You might find yourself in a situation where
you're pretty certain someone likes you but
they seem too scared to take that leap of
faith, they just don't want to get hurt again.
Studies have shown that a person with depression
deals with rejection in slightly different
ways, so that might be something to look out
for.
They might feel like you're out of their league.
Have you ever been attracted to someone but
it seems like you have zero chance with them?
We've all been there.
But depressed people might be feeling this
a lot more than the rest of us.
Studies have shown that depressed individuals
tend to feel a sense of worthlessness.
Like they're just not good enough.
In a romantic setting, this might cause them
to feel like you're totally out of their league
even when it's not even true.
A person with depression might want to be
with you more than anything, but sometimes,
they need a little bit of encouragement and
support to make them feel more at ease.
If they're not interested in sex, that doesn't
mean they're not into you.
Just because someone isn't interested in you
sexually, that doesn't mean they're not attracted
to you.
Studies have linked depression with sexual
dysfunction, perhaps a lowered sex drive for
example.
Sure, they might not be drooling over you,
but they could still be attracted to you.
Look for other signs of romantic attraction
and you might find that a person with depression
is totally into you.
They might seem desperate.
Desperation definitely doesn't show up in
all people with depression, but it is relatively
common.
Studies have even shown that depression is
linked with out-of-control sexual behavior.
They might have allowed their depression to
get the better of them and it could be impacting
their relationships in a negative way.
Of all the signs, this might be the easiest
to spot.
Some studies have even shown a link between
hyper sexuality and depressive symptoms.
They might seem awkward when they flirt.
Most people remember a time when flirting
got a little awkward, but with people with
depression, this might be a little more common.
A few studies have explored the link between
depression and lowered interpersonal communication.
Examples of this might be slowed or slurred
speech and awkward silences.
So look out for these signs.
If you don't look hard enough, you might not
even realize that they're trying to flirt
with you.
They might seem uncertain about the new romance.
It's always exciting when there's the spark
of a new romance.
Most of us feel a mixture of hope, excitement
and a little anxiety.
But a person with depression might feel a
lot more uncertain about a new romance than
others.
This is due to something called "Relational
Uncertainty", which is explored in a number
of studies.
Relational uncertainty is exactly what it
sounds like, people feeling uncertain about
their relationships.
The thing is, depressed individuals tend to
feel things a lot more than others.
So, if a person with depression is crushing
on you, they might also be feeling a lot of
anxiety at the same time.
They might have trouble looking into your
eyes.
Studies have shown that people with depression
have trouble maintaining eye contact and in
a romantic setting, this can be quite a challenge
for them.
We all know that the eyes are the window to
the soul, but how can depressed people hope
to connect with their crushes if they can't
even look them in the eye?
If you think a person with depression might
like you, watch them closely.
Maybe they seem like they want to look you
in the eye but they can't.
If so, then they might just have a major crush
on you.
Interested in more dating advice and romance
tips?
Then don't forget to subscribe.
And as always, thanks for watching our videos.